the intent of SOPA is to rein in the
offshore pirate sites that host a lot of
copyrighted content the challenge is
this that there is a regime called the
digital millennium copyright act or the
DMCA that creates a balance between the
tech industry the Internet industry and
the content industry largely Hollywood
record companies that balance today is
that if an Internet company is made
aware of copyrighted content on their
site they'll take it down that's working
pretty well domestically the problem is
that the DMCA doesn't reach offshore and
the Internet is a global phenomenon and
there's a bunch of sites in various
parts of the world that are hosting
intellectual property that was created
in the United States and hosting it
illegally the content creators can't get
at those sites because they're in
jurisdictions where US law has no effect
and so they they can't get directly at
the people who are breaking the law so
what they're trying to do is eliminate
or sort of take those sites off of the
US Internet make them invisible to us
users in order to do that they've asked
Congress to make social networks search
engines in Internet service providers a
domain name service providers payment
processors and advertisers responsible
for basically policing their users
basically preventing their users from
seeing this content so to make it sort
of to give you an analogy that would
make this a little bit more obvious this
is essentially making the phone company
responsible for the illegal behavior of
people using the phone network to commit
crimes the phone company is an
intermediary they're not committing the
crimes but if you made them responsible
for any crimes that were committed on
their network you would certainly have
an impact on crime you would also
clearly have an impact on the phone
company you know it would be a huge
burden on the phone company in the same
way this act places a huge burden on
internet services that you know a lot of
services that are built on
user-generated content like youtube or
or facebook are going to be responsible
for policing those users as you can
imagine they're very concerned about
this new brand new liability that that
this law would create for them I have
said in the past that that essentially
the internet and the internet culture is
all about empowering the individual
empowering the edge creating opportunity
and the content industry in this case is
really trying to control the behavior
and those two philosophies are really in
conflict let me give you a personal
example I my wife and I have gotten into
a series called Downton Abbey on the BBC
and a friend of ours alerted us to the
series and we started watching it and
it's a great sort of Upstairs Downstairs
story and it was very well done and we
went through the whole first season on
netflix in about two weeks our friend
says you know the second season is
available to wait great let's let's go
watch the second season so we went to
watch it and then I we get pointed to
this site I think it was called mega
upload and I'm starting to think oh I'm
not sure I want to do this I'm in the
middle of this debate I don't want to go
someplace that may not be legal I said I
don't like the sound of this let me go
see if I can find this content
legitimately and so I go to the BBC
website in Europe and sure enough the
entire second season every episode is
available for streaming from the BBC
site and in London so I launched episode
1 and the first thing that happens is a
little dialog box comes up and says oh
you're not in the United Kingdom you're
in the United States you can't watch
this what that made me realize is that
there's a whole lot of piracy that's
going on as a result of the fact that
you just can't get it I mean I would
have been happy to pay I pay netflix for
the content I would have been happy to
pay so it's not as much about you know
whether this is right or wrong the
problem is that the industry grew up in
an era where distribution was very
expensive and production was very
expensive and so they they parceled out
rights and very carefully rights too you
know windows in time you know release
windows in various different media and
then also geographic windows and and the
rights are all very
convoluted and complicated and we now
live in a world where everything is
accessible globally on the internet and
they're struggling to adapt to that and
they're trying to prevent the
distribution of content across this
network because it doesn't conform with
the way they've been licensing content
over time we think that that they're
going to need to ultimately adapt to it
because it doesn't really make sense to
criminalize all of your most passionate
fans you've got to find a way to serve
them in the medium that allows for
access to this content very
inexpensively and I think they can I
think you will